this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
manscape is the premier brand for the
men's below the waist
grooming and hygiene if you've been
watching this channel you know we're a
big fan of the perfect package what
comes with the lawnmower 3.0 and
everything else you see here
yup and look at this it comes with a
light and i use this
for my biosacs why'd you smell it
because i use it for my balls
it's a waterproof trimmer with skin safe
technology
so it's perfect and you do not cut up
your family jewels
however after using it for a few months
you do need to change the blades for the
cleanest and
closest shave possible enroll in the
peak hygiene plan
and get quarterly replacements for your
lawnmower trimmer 3.0
check it out looks just like this skin
safe replacement blade and then just
replace it and boom and got yourself
a brand new sharp blade with the
cleanest smoothest
shave so when it comes in the mail all
you got to do is take off the top clip
right here
and then you go boom like that and then
you go
boom like this and then you go boom like
that
and it's already ready to trim you see
that nice
oh yeah and then of course we got to put
on this part to protect the ball sacks
there we go that simple your replacement
pack
always comes with a free gift let's see
what we got this month
this month we got the foot duster foot
deodorant with active ph
control i'ma need that from a lot of
walking it's a 30
value totally free so to get all your
grooming needs done
go to manscape.com jknews
for 20 off the link is gonna be in the
description box below
you can click it click that and you get
free international shipping
your balls will thank you
[Music]
all right guys this story try not to cry
okay
oh no try not to cry it's one of those
sounds
okay i'm bracing myself i'm finally
gonna try not to cry video okay i'm not
crying
especially eugeo i know you're gonna cry
[ __ ]
okay i won't do it so this story a
[ __ ] animal
got ran over the head popped off and
it's [ __ ] rolling down the freeway
okay
so you got two out of the three wrong
what's the last one that could possibly
be
animal citizen
decides to go bungee jumping for the
last for the
last bucket list thing when they jump
out it went boing
and then the rope wrapped around their
neck and they [ __ ] pulled her out
that head went down the freeway i think
you're missing cry
and like people just going oh [ __ ] yes
yes that's a completely different it
would have to be
someone tortured an animal like they
were malicious
and then their head rolled down the
freeway
i don't know if you guys would cry for
that so what i meant was like children
animal and elderly right those are the
three soft spots for geo that's why i
said you said two out of the three and
then you hit
senior which is that's the category all
three
military guy is reunited with his wife
in a surprise moment
he farted but big surprise don't make me
cry
she fell in love with another man and
she has to bring it oh that's sad okay
of the rival branch that's right and a
navy guy
oh devastating and he's in the core
oh yeah you watch pearl harbor yeah
that's what happened
that's kind of what happened like she
thought he was dead in war and then she
got with his like best friend
josh harness yeah yeah they were both
hot they thought ben affleck died
yeah exactly and then he came back and
then she's like oh no i have two hot
guys that want me
but we cast away but he wasn't hot at
least she's stuck to the same branch we
know how [ __ ] up that is yeah
that's [ __ ] up not really oh yeah you
don't do that in the
yeah okay you don't hood hot let me tell
you about tony
this story is about tony williams and so
his story begins with the fact that
actually hold on
one second because i don't know if he's
gonna tell you his story let's just
let's just have him tell you his story
thank you he's a vlogger he's an old man
tony williams this is
tony hi tony he got interviewed
because of something that he did that
got the attention
of a lot of people and you will find out
right
now he saved cats
and children
well i'm tony williams my wife
joe who died about five months ago
oh i miss my lovely wife more than
more than i can ever say oh she misses
her but of course
i i'm here on my own
i have no family or friends
around here what a loser oh my next
tactic
he just recently moved back oh okay okay
to put on my
front window so that people
seeing it could know my position
know that i desperately needed this nice
conversation
it sounds as if i'm sorry for myself i'm
not um i just
know what i need i just need to have
a nice hanging conversation
um i don't want some of the shoulder to
cry on
um i want to be treated that penmanship
though you know he's
ancient reason
it's a font is this the one where the
kid writes him a letter
no okay dear old guy okay can i predict
this
the whole neighborhood gets together and
they'll hang out with him throw barbecue
and then he gets corona and dies
oh [ __ ] wait what no i would cry to that
though
okay yeah okay i'm still waiting for the
cry crying it's not it's not that his
wife died
okay that i know what it is it's one of
those sign language chimpanzees that get
get out oh it needs a friend just as bad
as him
wait now you guys are building up the
expectation of this when it's not that
crazy okay okay
it was already shown to you what was the
story about which
is i will clarify so tony his wife
passed away uh five months ago from
pancreatic cancer
she actually passed away nine days after
coming home from the hospital finding
out that she had pancreatic
wow so fast and so right before her
getting really really sick to the point
that she had to go to the hospital is
when they moved to a new location so
that's the reason why he doesn't have
family or friends nearby
and so after joe died his wife he
just felt like this unbearable like
loneliness
and so what he did is he initially
printed out
business cards that have his name
that have his name his phone number his
email
and so he said that he just had these
these business cards
in his back pocket like hopefully if
like just going to the store or
something he could strike up
some small conversation with someone and
like that could lead to him giving him
their
his card so they could have some sort of
communication but then that couldn't
happen because of covid right now like
it's really hard to meet people face to
face
why doesn't he join his local boxing gym
or something
because of colvin so let me remind you
he's 88 years old
okay and so funny and so like
online connections doesn't seem to
really be
he has an email though yeah but like to
actually go on social media that's a
whole nother
game right i might check it once a month
or something yeah so
everyone swiped on him oh i know right
what if he did try all that i tried
tinder i tried coffee meets bagel
i just can't seem to have a friend no so
i mean that like his fuller interview
because we had to shorten it but it's
like a three-minute interview and that
really pulls out your heart's strength
because he's really explaining how he
was just
really genuinely trying like he knew
about himself
like wait i don't feel right there's
something missing
i need human connection i hope at 88 you
know i need to do something about it
that's why at the end he said like it
might sound like i feel sorry for myself
but i don't i just know what i need and
i need human interaction
you know what it is too uh part of being
a man is that you're not supposed to say
these kinds of types of things which i
think
sucks and so i think it's great that
he's able to be like
no i need something yeah at 88 he's like
[ __ ] it i don't care that's what i need
he's like i'm a [ __ ] veteran and i
need something so then once the business
card idea didn't work because
even though he did hand them out to
people here and there no one really
reached out to him
that's what led him to go to this poster
which is the story
is the fact that he posted this on his
window outside his window and it says
i have lost joe my lovely wife and soul
mate i have no friends or family
no one to talk to i find the unremitting
silence
24 hours a day unbearable torture can no
one help me
and that poster went viral to the point
where he got
friends he got he got caught
we'll talk to you in court pal we'll
[ __ ] you in [ __ ] court
take that down there's a line going
outside of your house now
like what the hell you're gonna take
care of that line so then he got
interviewed by like daily mail and the
media
and then that's how like his phone
number his email got spread around
through the whole world
by the way this is joe his wife that
passed oh i was like danny moves on fast
that's what i
thought i was like he got a girlfriend
out of this are they posing in front of
a tsunami
it looks like advisor yeah what if they
what if the captain that was he's like
i'm not looking for anything serious
yeah so this is when they got married
back in i think 1980
in every photo so this is actually his
second wife
uh he didn't age a bit because he's
already aged fast and she's the one that
looks like
she's she's gotten older but he looks
the same
he was stressful to be around that's
what that teaches you actually
actually so uh his
okay well well before i get there
back to the poster he looked 88 when he
was 20. that got a lot of attention to
the point where now he's saying that he
answers about a hundred
calls and that his answering machine is
full
with a whole bunch of messages that he
has had thousands and thousands of
emails
people contacting him from all around
the world like the us canada australia
the middle east spain
iceland and so he's been having long
like lovely long conversations with
people and he says that
as soon as like all this dies down he
really hopes to have
a nice list of people that he can have
like a long-term relationship with
he's like the tubers that i knew before
they blew up and then they blow up and
somebody's like yo can i get a picture
with the old man and he's like uh no
no no no yeah sorry i'm sorry yeah okay
now back to not doing collabs anymore
yeah
not anymore so back to steve's comment
about him being a difficult person
in this one particular article they did
interview
joe's sister like her family
and apparently they had said that
uh what's his name again tony tony
williams tony
that tony was kind of difficult when it
came down to
the the funeral part because because of
covid times there's only a limited
number of people that can attend a
funeral or awake
and so i think it was like max that 10
people and so he had
his own brother as one of the 10 people
instead of the sister's husband so joe's
sister's husband and so last minute
tony's brother bailed and and then so
the sister wanted to bring her husband
and then tony said no they had like a
little thing and to the point where
apparently she says that he's kind of a
difficult person to get along with
sometimes you don't like your sister's
husband that happened to me
[ __ ] sake yeah poor jeff i know he's
the best we like jeff
my name is yeah i don't know whose call
that is to me
yeah i mean there's always there's
always her husband right that's why
she's saying he's being difficult yeah
but there's layers there
yeah like her perspective of it is like
i'm immediate family
yeah but the husband's not yeah there's
layers there bro
i get it he's the husband and i'm like i
don't know if that's difficult i thought
when he said difficult like he was
trying to climb in the casket
at the same time i would still
understand that and i wouldn't even call
that difficult
yeah also it kind of seems like the
sister's a little salty because she's
like
i mean you know a lot of people lose
their significant others but people just
move on with their lives
what a little c that's a little c right
yeah that's your sister
you're so perfect yeah it's like you we
all have sisters
and do we all have husbands if you're if
your
significant other dies you're allowed to
be difficult damn like that
it's like shut the [ __ ] up she was being
a little [ __ ] and he's like well you
can't have your significant other then
how do you like it this is her exact
quote in a way i feel sorry for him
because
in a way because he idolized joe but he
can be a difficult person to get on with
sometimes and he does have a habit of
upsetting people
well it's like you human doesn't and
that literally everyone
yeah this actually reminds me of a story
you guys know who dak prescott is
yeah he's the um dallas cowboys
quarterback okay it doesn't matter
so he got called out recently because he
started talking about depression
and he's a [ __ ] star quarterback for
the dallas cowboys maybe the biggest
media market so where people are like
stop being a [ __ ] yes
really in fact skip bayless of espn he's
a good commentator who constantly is
like uh
he tries to be controversial and stuff
oh he's one of those guys he was like
you know it's pretty [ __ ] to talk about
your feelings and
[ __ ] and this is one another one of
those things i think that we all do
where we look at men and go like you
know and my grandpa this too
but it's like you shouldn't be such a
[ __ ] and all this stuff
but i think that what he's doing is just
a human thing where he's just trying to
connect with people
but it's not seen as okay to do that
sometimes male or female sometimes
but especially dudes like if you're
trying to feel like he's mourning his
wife
dude like let him [ __ ] mourn his wife
it's only been five months later
but her own sister's like oh come on get
over it yeah you know like that's what i
mean by
this whole thing that we all do to
people sometimes and we do it to
everybody but
but this whole thing was like oh you
shouldn't you shouldn't dump too much of
your
stuff on people and i just think that
that's [ __ ] i think it's an old way
of thinking
that should go away it sucks that's why
everyone needs therapy
yes yeah so pay somebody get away from
me how bad
badass is it that one of the most
masculine people you can think of dak
[ __ ] prescott the dallas cowboys star
talking about depression yeah and yeah
mental health yeah
it's normalizing it that's dope exactly
it just sucks that that's the response
you got though yeah
from one guy yeah there's a support from
one guy that doesn't even play football
he talks about football
across from a guy who played football
[ __ ] sharp
he should have called him out on that
exactly y'all [ __ ] who's the real [ __ ]
i got how many injuries and had to take
steroids
[Music]
foreign
[Music]